tennessee's US Senate race figures to be
crucial in both parties efforts to try
to control the US Senate after this year
correspondent Steve Harrigan is in
Nashville tonight the most expensive
race in Tennessee history could
determine control of the US Senate it's
gonna be highly competitive there's
going to be huge amount of money from
the outside poured into this race
especially if it looks like it might be
the pivot that turns on whether the
Democrats control the Senate the
Republican representative Marsha
Blackburn a self-described hardcore
conservative who carries a pistol in her
purse proclaims her support for
president Trump often I stand when the
president walks in the room and yes I
stand when I hear the star-spangled
banner the Democrat former Governor Phil
Bredesen calls himself a problem solver
and rarely mentions the president at all
the last he has to take on the president
or kind of take on national politics
that's probably all the better for him
the more you can keep a local on
statewide issues I think that portends
better for him come November it is a
balancing act for a Democrat in a state
Trump won by more than 20 points
despite Trump's popularity Blackburn
knows she's in for a fight I think it is
closed because my opponent did service
governor for two terms and he has run
statewide three times this would be as
fourth statewide race and people are
familiar with this name and what is
likely to be a tight race bredesen is
expected to do well in the city's
Blackburn in the suburbs while both
battle for the rural vote they've been
promising this and that ever since he's
been in office and haven't done nothing
we need people it's gonna be in there do
something to help back his agenda to get
America back on the road again President
Trump won some counties in Tennessee
with almost 90 percent of the vote the
question now for this Senate race is
whether that popularity is transferable
Bret it's American live in Nashville
Steve thank